[Music]  we don't just do shotguns here so this  is actually a rifle this is something  somebody would use to go to Africa with  you can go to Africa with this yep how  you go when people go and they hunt cape  buffalo treatment and they let them take  rifles overseas ya know so if you want  to see the bullet on that one to make it  the that's crazy man that's not real  that's not real  what's not real that's not real that's  not really there's no room mMmmm  they let somebody fly to Africa not only  with this big heavy ass gun with this -  yep no way they won't even let me  [ __ ] trouble with a lighter can you  do this yep  trapping what's your thing here okay  cool